Speaker 1: So we are starting to see a bit
of a shift already among individuals who have
been critical of Donald Trump starting to
go in the direction of if Trump runs, I wouldn't
run.
And if Trump runs, I would support him.
The latest as Nikki Haley, Nikki Haley, former
Republican governor of South Carolina.
She was Donald Trump's ambassador to the United
Nations for a relatively brief period of time.
Nikki Haley is now saying if Trump runs, she
would not run.
And if Trump runs, she would support Donald
Trump.
Just recently, she was critical of Trump,
saying that Trump would be judged harshly
by history.
It seemed as though Nikki Haley maybe was
starting to be more direct and forthright
about her reservations about Donald Trump.
And at the time when we reported that, I said
to you, I think this is merely posturing.
I think this is Nikki Haley putting out some
sort of very, very light possible critique.
Whether we can even call it a critique is
a question mark.
And she's trying to play both sides.
And none of these people spoke out when Trump
was still in power.
None of them spoke out when they were still
working for Donald Trump.
And it seems that that's exactly what it is.
We're going to look at a clip here.
Here is Nikki Haley saying, yeah, if Donald
Trump if Donald Trump runs, she would support
it and she would not run.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: He still has a lot of popularity.
If he runs again in twenty twenty four, will
you support him?
If he decides that he's going to run, would
that preclude any sort of run that you would
possibly make yourself.
I would not run it from.
And I would talk to him about it.
That's something that we'll have a conversation
about at some point if that decision is something
that has to be made.
But, yeah, I would absolutely I had a great
working relationship with him.
I appreciated the way he let me do my job.
I thought we did some fantastically great
foreign policy things together.
And look, I just want to keep building on
what we accomplished and not once again.
When was the last time that you talked to
him?
After the election, before January 6th or
after before January.
Speaker 1: So there it is, I think that these
this is first of all, this is significant
because there's lots lots of people talking
about Nikki Haley running in 2020 for herself.
There are many Republicans who are it's Nikki
Haley is not the traditional Republican wing,
but she's also also not full.
Q Kuhnen.
She's just kind of in the middle.
And there are there's a contingent of the
Republican Party that likes the idea of Nikki
Haley running for the Republican nomination.
And when she so clearly says if Trump runs,
I won't even try to challenge him.
And if Trump runs, I will I will support him.
That signals to us something about how the
20 24 Republican primary would go if it were
held today.
And that is exactly the way I've been talking
about it, which is based on Republican support
for Trump right now.
It's Trump's if he wants it, if Trump fails
to play kingmaker in the 2022 midterms, if
Trump supports Marjorie Taylor Greene and
Lauren Bobo, Bobert and Madison Cawthorn,
and they lose that Steele's political capital
from Donald Trump.
And if that happens, his fundraising beyond
2022 will likely be hurt.
And if that happens, it's not seeming super
likely that Donald Trump will run in 2024.
But if it were held today.
With something like 80 percent of Republican
voters wanting, Trump involved 60 percent
of Republican voters believing Trump won the
November 20 20 election.
It is Trump's for the taking at this point
in time.
Let me know what, other than the success or
failure of Trump in members of Congress and
the Senate could determine what Trump does
in twenty twenty four?
I think Trump's health is always a question
mark.
I mean, he's obese.
He's not a healthy guy.
I think that that that four years from now,
three and a half years from now, that could
be a factor.
But let me know what else you think other
than just his popularity.
We'll take a quick break.
After the break, we will have the latest very
strange comments from Senator John Kennedy.
No relation to the Democratic Kennedy family.
I also have a voicemail for you.
Some people are very concerned about me, actually.
I'll tell you why.
We'll hear the latest from Mike Lendell and
much, much more.
Stay with us